peu
[Musique]
et
dans très exactement dix semaines les
téléspectateurs de paris lille nancy
strasbourg pourront recevoir en noir ou
en couleur les images de la troisième
chaîne comment les capter d'ici la fin
de l'année
micros et caméras essaiera de vous aider
en vous parlant haut de vos appareils de
vos antennes et enfin des programmes
mais aujourd'hui commençons par vaux
télévisuelle télévision oui est-ce que
vous avez la deuxième chaîne
oui c'est bon est ce que vous savez
comment faire croire en la troisième
cherchent pas du tout où il n'avait pas
une idée que comment vous allez pouvoir
vous servir de la troisième chaîne
sabrina deyris pas bon non pas encore
pansé les troisièmes sienne
c'était comment faire pour régler vos
postes non pas du tout je pense que vous
appuyez sur le bouton j'aime sioniste et
ça le fait non je ne suis plus ne sera
pas question parce que la troisième
chaîne n'existait pas encore alors ce
n'est pas être mais un service rendu et
samaa prochain l'ancien de simplement
vous savez pas mais je suppose qu'il ne
faillait les petits boutons qui font 1 2
3 4 5 6 et j'ai pas je suppose
simplement foyers sur les points que
j'ai fait
si ça se règle par touches je sais je
les touche pour la compacte et la
troisième chaîne je n'ai pas besoin
d'antenne supplémentaire je pense que
l'antenne de la deuxième suffit c'est
tout ce que je sais c'est la 3eme chaoui
et comme on est tellement je pousse le
troisième bouton cette eau et tout
marche bien savoir assez peu concluants
ces interviews vous ne trouvez vous pas
en fait cette confusion vient du grand
nombre de téléviseurs en six avis il
faut en effet se rappeler qu'il ya en
france un parc au d'au moins 13 millions
de récepteurs sur ses 13 millions
il ya encore un million et demi qui
construit avant 1962 ne reçoivent que la
première chaîne ce que les techniciens
appel vhf
ces appareils ne recevront jamais ni la
seconde ni la troisième tous les autres
soit 11 millions et demi
construit de 1962 à 1972 à quelques
200000 exceptions près peuvent
aujourd'hui recevoir les signaux de la
deuxième chaîne et par conséquent
peuvent recevoir les signaux de la
troisième chaîne au fur et à mesure de
sa mise en service sur ses 11 millions
et demi environ 8 millions construit à
peu près entre 62 et 69 un système de
réglage de la réception de la seconde
chaîne et la troisième chaîne est
entièrement manuelle
[Musique]